[Music]
[Applause]
it's almost like after 30 years he's
become an overnight sensation because it
feels like the rest of america is now
experiencing chris mad dog russo because
he's on first take with stephen a smith
chris has been doing this for her a long
long time battling anybody everybody mad
dog unleashed on siriusxm sirius
that's channel 82 host of high heat on
major league baseball network congrats
chris on this uh overnight success
uh out of nowhere danny you know how
much of love's coming on how you doing
paolo okay i'm good i'm good you argue
for a living but when you go on first
take how much say do you have in those
topics that you're going to be exploring
you know more than i thought uh you know
um they did a little baseball a couple
weeks ago
i suggested maybe something on
shishevsky yesterday because obviously
you know in the duke game on
on saturday and the fact they play today
at noon
uh so i thought you had to do a little
college basketball um
you know i'm careful that stevie's show
so i mean i get you know a new guy on
the block i don't want to make any waves
i thought maybe you had to do something
on calvin ridley you know with the
gambling thing with the one year either
they agreed on that anyway
but i mean i think you know
i will basically
i will be gentle but i suggest you know
what the hell i've been doing this for a
long time and as you said it's almost
like i've been debating my whole life
half the time i'm serious i'm talking to
myself for three hours so as a result i
come up with topics i did it with mike
for 19 years uh i've been on all these
i've been on with your show a million
times you and i have had plenty of
debates going back to your days at
sports center so it's almost like i've
been trained to do this so i'm usually
fairly comfortable i think the two
sports i'm a little shaky with right now
and there was a big boxing match steve's
great with that i'd have a little work
to do
and nba regular season you know
especially right now we're sort of in
and out of the clouds when i'm more into
the college
um you know maybe it could be a little
spotty but uh you know i'll adapt the
way i have do that but i've had a little
say i've had some say in what yeah in a
two-hour thing that's a long time two
hours to talk so i've had a little say a
little saying the art of winning an
argument
what is your art of winning an argument
well in the old days with mike it was a
case of you know out screaming him
and um
and you know maybe figuring out a way to
get you know sort of wearing him down
you know the battle of attrition
and eventually mike would or me would
just throw up the right flag you know
what i'm not going to win this one the
hell is it all right you win
on in this particular situation where
you don't want to come across as a
loudmouth bully
as you said you know who in america
knows who chris russo is so you have to
be a little more gentle
and again you know i still consider
myself almost as a guest more so as a
semi co-host so i don't want to overstep
my bounds
um but the great thing about him i don't
know if you know him that well dan you
may i don't know what your relationship
but the great thing about him is
he doesn't care
who gets to credit as long as your show
is good a lot of guys wouldn't do it
that way you know in my show i've been
doing it for 10 years you're a guest and
you're going to follow my lead he
doesn't seem to have that attitude so as
a result if i want to scream and yell
about where curry is with bird i want to
scream and yell about where wilson is
with uh rogers
at least in unless the first couple of
appearances let me do that so uh i think
i've learned in my life not to go too
crazy because you can win an argument
and still look bad yeah
you know you can all right you win but
it doesn't come across well
and you also want to be likable i mean
right yeah you're on tv you're on radio
there's got to be a little likability
factor
so you want to be able to get your point
across great if you win
but have some fun doing it and you want
that to come across so if you have to
lose an argument for the sake of losing
it because it's good tv or good radio i
think i didn't know this 15 years ago i
probably know that now
he's uh mad dog russo by the way he's
got uh a new series of episodes on his
digging up the pan past podcast debuts
this month you focus on the history of
the ncaa tournament first episode is
magic bird 1979 title game and uh you
can get that on the sirius xm app uh
what's the one thing that you would want
the audience to take away from this that
maybe you discovered on bird magic 1979
yeah it's a this is going to be all
about the 80s um
and uh we did the first half first uh 40
years uh
last year so this is the second part
we're going to break it down into five
parts the switch from nbc to cbs the
rise of the big east classic games and
the bird magic thing now obviously magic
and bird are you're not going to get
them so
yeah you know i did i did the interviews
that larry brown was at the games i did
packer i did bob ryan i think the one
thing that i didn't realize
ryan insisted and he was there that bird
was hurt
that he hurt his wrist
sometime in the course late in that year
and didn't feel right that night now he
shot seven for 21
and was not a factor in the game as you
know michigan state where you and i are
old enough to know this michigan state
was a much better team and byrd was not
a hundred percent that's what uh that's
what uh ryan said emphatically
uh packer his theme is what you and i
have always thought about too at least
you know nobody really quite knew
watching those two players how great
they were going to be in the nba
magic slow couldn't shoot
bird you know you know slow
you know not a great defender how's how
would his game translate and packer on
two or three cuts
in that episode which is 40 minutes long
in two or three cuts said none of us
thought that the two of them were going
to be great nba players including al
mcguire
so i think those two little tidbits
are interesting i mean number two danny
you remember this
i did two because i was 18 i was in
college
as a freshman bird played two great
games
that indiana state did before that
championship game they beat moncrief
and arkansas
in the regional final i was a year after
mark arkansas got to the final four but
ron brewer and marvin delphi had
graduated so only moncrief was left they
won by a basket
and moncrieff and bird were great as you
know and then in the semifinals they
beat aguirre
from depaul and aguirre was great ray
meyer and that game was by a basket so
they had played two unbelievable games
and then they played this terrible game
in the final so i thought that was
interesting a lot of interesting little
tidbits um you know you and i would
remember it because you and i are old
enough yeah i mean probably a little
younger than me but we're about the same
age so we and you're you and you're a
good player as it was you remember all
these games but even i picked up on
something that's why these podcasts are
good because you do all these interviews
with older guys who are so sharp as
attack who give you good information
i'll give you one that you'll find
fascinating you ready for this
i did behind on the big east to talk to
him and on his game that he lost to
indiana
in 87 when he lost indiana the chaperone
who is in charge of getting syracuse to
and from new orleans
was crushed
that they lost in the lost indiana
when they went back there in 2003
in new orleans
behind gets on the bus with the
chaperone and the first thing he says
let's win this championship it was the
same chaperone from 1986
things like that that you pick up that
are interesting you know
uh if
bird or magic would be better in today's
nba which one that's
you're you can answer that probably
better than i can i think bird would be
great i think both would be great i mean
magic you have to wonder a little bit
about his quickness his three-point
shooting
you know if the game's different you
know he was a he was a wonderful fan and
he wasn't unbelievably fast so it's a
it's a and his three-point shooting
berber is a great three-point shooter so
i have no i think bird might be a little
better organized today than magic would
be because bird was a great well they
both were great passers but bird was a
better shooter than magic and a better
three-point shooter and everything else
so maybe birds game translates but i
think if you're an all-time great you're
an all-time great and i think both of
them
uh would be great today and i made the
point with stephen a last week and i
don't know if you saw it or heard about
it and you might disagree or not and i'm
not arguing body of work
but if you ask me in the peak of their
career
in a seven-game series against an equal
team who i'd rather have berta lebron i
might take bird that's how good he was
um i think larry
if he had stayed healthy we always loved
to have that caveat but it wasn't until
lebron was around 30 when i said he's a
better basketball player than larry
because there was a season where larry
averaged
pretty close to a triple-double and i
think it was when he was 29 or so and
you know it was 39 and eight for larry
and and larry wasn't about numbers
everybody's about numbers now
uh you know if you're 39 and eight
you're gonna go i'm gonna average a
triple double you know bird that that
you know he didn't calculate games that
way but right um
if you said it's one game i think chris
then it then it's an interesting
argument but i said shoot i i said
series you know on a seven okay so one
game
would that be any different would you
would you take bird over lebron one game
must i think i i think he's a better
shooter he's a better shooter than
lebron is and he's a better outside and
he's a better free throw shooter
um and here's the thing that i argued
and you would remember it well and i
think there's something to it i've seen
lebron he was bad against dallas the
year they lost yeah he played terribly
in that series
you've been around forever you ever see
bird in a big when he was healthy you
ever see bird in a big series
lay an egg i saw him i saw him have a
bad shooting performance i i had the bad
game against the lakers the year that
they magic's baby hook yeah because i
was at that game and i you know bird and
bird had a chance at the end yeah i had
a wide open three yeah he had a wide
open james
james yeah i was there
wow i didn't know that you were at that
game game five in in the 87 where were
you sitting that night uh i was way up
way up
that was before sport were you doing
sportscenter at the time i was at cnn
wow you were at that game that's one of
the all-time great games the the magic
baby hook yeah
yeah wow but i mean i was fortunate to
have been around
the nba in the early i the only person i
didn't see in in person was bill russell
saul wilt maravich you know
all of those great teams came into
cincinnati the cincinnati royals so i
got a chance to see
great players so when people say well
let's argue this
you know i can i at least have a
reference point
you sir oscar you're old enough to have
seen oscar as a royal yeah before he
went to milwaukee yes
we didn't realize how great he was
because the royals weren't any good
but he did this every night where he'd
give you 25 26 a game great free throw
shooter rebounder but we also knew of
him at the university of cincinnati so
right so a lot of times we see somebody
for the first time we go oh my god did
you see that guy well we had seen oscar
for you know six seven years before he
emerged on the scene in milwaukee when
he won an nba championship but i'm
missing the missing ingredient that's
right you grew up in cincinnati so you
saw all those royal teams were you at
the are you old enough were you at the
game and when koozie put himself down he
blew that five-point lead against the
knicks no i was not but uh
that was that was tough we saw that you
know that that made the knicks break the
record for consecutive wins that game
yeah was it 18 or 19 in a row 18 i think
in a row yeah yeah which the lakers
which the lakers obliterated you know
two or three years later but you know
tell them danny uh koozie put himself in
a game with a five-point lead what was
it 30 seconds left or something crazy
like that they lost
something like that it was sad when you
saw it because that's where somebody
doesn't realize they shouldn't be in the
game and koozie was a player coach and
he put himself in the game and i think
had a couple of turnovers there they
ended up losing uh before i left years
six years after he retired two six years
after uh if you were going to arbitrate
baseball
and it's lockout
how would you
what's the solution here chris
i think they're going to get something
done you can't sit there and tell me
this international draft thing i know
tie-in that's not gonna i think that
i whether it's today tomorrow i i do
think they're gonna get something done
the owners today
listen i know everybody wants to kill
the owners so i'll go the other way i
mean think about what the owners have
given to players here danny you you've
been following this forever they went
minimum salary went up to 700 000 from
570 and then the deal goes to 770. they
took about the free agent compensation
situation
they it went the luxury tax went from
208 to 230 million
you know from the last agreement last
year into this year at 230. they minim
the
they got away the market manipulation
that chris bryant nonsense that we saw
at the cubs when he got sent down to the
model leagues and they for service time
they only took 12 postseason teams when
they wanted 14 and here's the big one
they had never given a nickel into this
they put 40 million dollars into the
salary arbitration thing for one and
two-year players so a guy like carbon
burns who won a cy young would not be
eligible for a lot of money
now in subsequent years if they signed
off this they'd have 40 million dollars
to figure out how to use if you're a
part of the player association so to me
if i'm a player i say hold on now we got
minimum salary we got cbt
we got only the amount of playoff teams
we wanted we got uh no jet pack
compensation we got salaries i'm an
idiot let's go i'm signing the contract
but
you know they came up with this
international jet thing i think this
will get settled here shortly and i
mentioned this yesterday and you
probably agree can you imagine
if on april 15th
on the 75th anniversary of jackie
robinson
they're not playing in major league
ballparks
in this day and age i know
think about that then i know
i know
i know they have to play they got to
figure this that's the most the biggest
embarrassment in the world a week before
the nfl draft and they're on and they're
on a lockout strike when jackie robinson
75 years ago played first base for the
for the dodgers against the boston
braves and they're not playing baseball
that you're not going to win you're dead
you're finished in this day and age so i
think they're going to get something
done oh it's great to talk to you
congrats on the success there with the
first take thank you buddy that's uh mad
dog russo you can see him on first take
every wednesday with uh stephen a smith
and also he has a new series of episodes
for his podcast digging up the past
available siriusxm app